[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Serien in allen einen schönen
guten Abend es gibt jede Menge samstags
Sport heute Christian den hast du im
Blick ich habe viel Schönes dabei guten
Abend und hier sind unsere Themen des
Tages
alte Beziehung neuer Schwung Deutschland
und Japan wollen enger zusammenarbeiten
und so von Ländern wie China
unabhängiger werden
ein Besuch viel Symbolik zum 9 jahrestag
der krimination zeigt sich russlands
Präsident Putin auf der Halbinsel
Freiheitskampf und Barrikaden vor 175
Jahren begann in Berlin die Revolution
die als ein Grundstein für die deutsche
Demokratie gilt
[Musik]
in Zeiten großer globaler und
geopolitischer Unsicherheiten besinnen
sich Deutschland und Japan auf
gemeinsame Interessen die
Bundesregierung reiste jetzt erstmals zu
Regierungskonsultationen ins Land der
aufgehenden Sonne Ergebnis Berlin und
Tokio wollen militärisch und
wirtschaftlich enger zusammenarbeiten
was das bedeutet erklärt Elisabeth
Schmidt
Ankunft im Regen und Begrüßung mit
Regenschirm in Deutschland haben
japanische Gastfreundschaft der Kanzler
und sechs wichtige Minister sind nach
Tokyo gereist auch um zu lernen sagen
sie vor allem beim Thema Energie und
rohstoffsicherheit der russische
Überfall auf die Ukraine genauso wie die
corona-pandemie zuvor haben uns
schmerzhaft vor Augen geführt welche
Schwierigkeiten es geben kann wenn zu
starke wirtschaftliche Abhängigkeiten in
kritischen Bereichen bestehen es geht
vor allem um Halbleiter Wasserstoff von
Mineralien in Japan kümmert sich seit
vielen Jahren eine eigene Behörde um
Rohstoffimporte und stabile Lieferketten
für deutsche Unternehmen vor Ort ein
Vorbild mehr als jede zweite deutsche
Firma nutzt mittlerweile japanische
Lieferanten auch bei der
Verteidigungspolitik wollen beide
Ländern noch enger zusammenarbeiten
Deutschland verspricht ein weiteres
Bundeswehr Schiff in den Indopazifik zu
schicken Einigkeit auch beim Thema
Ukraine
wir haben nochmals bekräftigt wie
wichtig der Zusammenhalt Gleichgesinnter
Staaten und die Fortführung harter
Sanktionen gegen Russland und eine
starke Unterstützung der Ukraine ist um
die russische Aggression sobald wir
möglich zu beenden
Worte die der Kanzler gerne hört Japan
für Deutschland immer mehr ein stabiler
Anker in Asien mehr militärische
Zusammenarbeit mit Japan und auch mehr
Handel Deutschland soll nie wieder
abhängig sein von einem Land wie beim
Gas aus Russland und sich schützen
vorlieferingpässen das heißt dann auch
mehr Japan weniger China die deutsche
Handelspolitik wird neu aufgestellt
deutschland sucht den Kontakt zu neuen
alten Freunden Zeiten Wände bei der
verteidigungs- und Wirtschaftspolitik
bei seinem Besuch in Japan fand der
Bundeskanzler auch Worte zum Haftbefehl
des internationalen
strafgerichtshofsgegend Putin niemand
stehe über Recht und Gesetz so Scholz
auch der US-Präsident begrüßte die
Entscheidung als gerechtfertigt und sehr
starkes Signal gestern erging der
Haftbefehl gegen Russlands Präsidenten
wegen der Verschleppung Tausender
ukrainischer Kinder Moskau bezeichnet
den Schritt als bedeutungslos Präsident
Putin selbst ist heute auf die Halbinsel
Krim gereist und wollte damit an den 9
jahrestag der Annexion erinnern für
Russland ist die Krim wegen ihrer
geographischen Lage wirtschaftlich und
militärisch sehr bedeutend nach einer
inszenierten Volksabstimmung 2014
gliederte Putin des Gebiet in die
Russische Föderation ein weder
Referendum noch Annexion wurden
international anerkannt über den Tag
heute berichtet Nina geil
es war ein untypischer Auftritt für
Vladimir Putin abseits der
Menschenmengen und Russland Flaggen
besuchte eine Kunstschule auf der Krim
kein Wort von ihm zum Jahrestag der
Annexion den Ton setzten die offiziellen
vor Ort
heute verstehen wir dass die Ereignisse
die damals in Sebastopol begannen zu
weiteren Entwicklungen führten der
Wiederbelebung des Donbass all das
führte zu den Ereignissen die wir heute
sehen ich bin sicher es wird mit unserem
bedingungslosen siegenten
zehntausende haben seit der Annexion von
9 Jahren die Krim verlassen wer hier
geblieben ist steht hinter Putin oder
behält seine Meinung für sich
nein wir bereuen nicht dass wir Russland
beigetreten sind
ich habe keine Angst fühle mich nur
etwas unwohl aber ich vertraue unsere
Armee wir werden gewinnen
die propaganda-show fällt in diesem Jahr
kleiner aus als sonst möglicherweise aus
Angst vor ukrainischen Angriffen
russische Einrichtungen auf der Krim
sind immer wieder Ziele ukrainische
Attacken Sebastopol ein wichtiger
Stützpunkt der Schwarzmeerflotte und
russischer Truppen
es sind jetzt mehr Truppen dort
stationiert es sind andere Waffensysteme
dort stationiert und der
laufende Krieg Russlands gegen die
Ukraine wird maßgeblich auch von von
russischen Einrichtungen auf der Krim
unterstützt für Putin ist die Krim ein
wichtiges Symbol die Annexion hatte er
persönlich vorangetrieben seine
Botschaft wohl deshalb heute kein Grund
zur Sorge alles unter Kontrolle
wenige Stunden nach diesem Putin
Auftritt die Meldung Russland und die
Ukraine verlängern das getreideabkommen
das bestätigte der türkische Präsident
Erdogan der das Abkommen mit vermittelt
hatte die Exporte durch Schwarzmeer sind
wichtig für viele Länder in denen
Menschen von Hunger bedroht sind
zumindest hier ein Ansatz von Einigkeit
während es in der Ukraine wieder
zahlreiche russische Drohnen und
Raketenangriffe gab Maike Verlag violand
massive Zerstörung in saporija hier
sollen gestern russische Raketen
eingeschlagen sein laut ukrainischer
Luftwaffe zählte Russland in der Nacht
auf gleich mehrere Regionen
auch die Kämpfe an der Front gehen
weiter neben bachmut besonders in den
Orten Lehmann Marinka schachtarsk und
auf Dirk
auf diefgas vom Krieg bereits schwer
gezeichnet der Beschuss ist konstant
von 25.000 Bewohnern haben noch immer
etwa 2000 Menschen in der Industriestadt
aus
wir sind es bereits gewohnt aber es
macht mir Angst zu sehen wie Menschen
getötet werden
eine Spezialeinheit der ukrainischen
Polizei sucht die Menschen auf die doch
noch bereit sind zu fliehen eine von
ihnen ist Svetlana masurina seit April
lebt sie mit ihrem Sohn in einem Keller
ihr Haus zerstört
ich gehe nur wegen meinem Sohn ich
möchte dass er gut leben kann
rund um die Stadt halten die Soldaten
den Angriffen stand aber der
Munitionsmangel macht ihnen sorgen
das größte Problem ist dass der Feind
mehr Munition hat wenn die
Voraussetzungen gleich wären dann würde
sich der Verlauf des Krieges sehr
schnell ändern
Russland sucht aber offenbar neue
Soldaten für den Fronteinsatz die
Söldnergruppe Wagner kündigte an bis
Mitte Mai rund 30.000 neue Kämpfer unter
Vertrag nehmen zu wollen
Anne Brühl ist für uns in Kiew Anne
wieder gab es zahlreiche russische
Angriffe auf die Ukraine wie hast du die
letzten 24 Stunden erlebt
ja hier in Kiew gibt es immer wieder
luft-
ganz im Westen und viele Ukraine haben
das als direkte Reaktionen auf den
Haftbefehl für Vladimir Putin gewertet
die Kämpfe konzentrieren sich ja vor
allen Dingen auf den Osten vor allen
Dingen auf bachmut die letzte offene
Verbindungsstraße aus ukrainischem
Gebiet die Geräte in den letzten Tagen
immer heftiger unter russischen Beschuss
und viele hier fragen sich ob und wann
denn die Frühlingsoffensive der Ukraine
beginnen wird auf die ja viele hier ihre
Hoffnung setzen ob das im Osten sein
wird oder vielleicht doch eher im Süden
von saporicia aus Richtung melittopol
und schließlich dann auch Richtung Grimm
von der Präsident selenski ja immer
behauptet hatte der Krieg habe dort
begonnen und er werde dort enden live
aus Kiew eine Brühl vielen Dank
nach einer Reihe kostspieliger
Fehlschläge und trotz eines 50
Milliarden frankenkredits der
Zentralbank steckt die Schweizer
Traditionsbank Kredit Suisse tief in der
Krise laut Medienberichten verfolgen die
Aufsichtsbehörden des Landes einen Plan
A demnach soll die UBS das größte
Schweizer Geldhaus die Übernahme des
angeschlagenen Konkurrenten prüfen
spätestens bis zum Handel statt am
Montag soll eine Lösung gefunden sein
würde die Credit Suisse komplett
geschluckt entstünde eines der größten
Bankhäuser Europas
in Frankreich weiterhin große Wut über
die geplante Rentenreform der Regierung
und gestern Abend gingen wieder Tausende
auf die Straße in Paris und anderen
Städten gab es heftige Krawalle dutzende
Demonstranten wurden festgenommen über
das ganze Wochenende sind im ganzen Land
Protestaktionen geplant die Regierung
muss sich am Montag eine
Misstrauensvotum stellen denn Präsident
macron hatte die Reform ohne Finale
Abstimmung durch das Parlament gedrückt
und damit die Vertrauensfrage ausgelöst
Strom erzeugen durch klimaschädliche
Kohle damit soll ja bis 2038 Schluss
sein die Grünen wollen das schon bis
2030 schaffen und zwar das ist seit
heute klar auch im Osten von Deutschland
dies seit notwendig um die Klimaziele zu
erreichen heißt es vor einer Klausur der
grünen Bundestagsfraktion Kritik kommt
aus den östlichen Bundesländern aber
auch vom Koalitionspartner mehr von Ines
Trams
die Zeit der Kohlebagger in den
ostdeutschen Ländern sollen nicht erst
2038 enden wie in NRW soll auch hier
acht Jahre früher das Aus für die Kohle
kommen so will es die Bundestagsfraktion
der Grünen nächste Woche beschließen ein
Schritt für das Klima so heißt es und
für die Menschen er ist gleichzeitig
notwendig um angesichts einer zusehends
unrentablen Kohle Verstromung in den
kommenden Jahren endlich Planungs- und
Investitionssicherheit herzustellen wenn
wir den Rahmen schaffen 2030 zu sagen im
mit der Kohle im Osten ist Schluss dann
können wir gleichzeitig jetzt schon
beginnen den Strukturwandel so zu
gestalten dass wir neue Technologien
ansiedeln und damit auch neue Jobs der
Zukunft schaffen und damit auch großes
Wachstumspotenzial für die Region
gestalten gelingen soll der frühere
Ausstieg mit vorgezogenen Milliarden
Hilfen und mit der Umstellung auf
Gaskraftwerke und Wasserstoff Widerstand
kommt von den unionsministerpräsidenten
von Sachsen und Sachsen-Anhalt aber auch
von der SPD
die sind halt auch nicht in fünf Jahren
zu bauen und die Frage ist mit welchen
Gas werden die denn eigentlich befeuert
also dann müssen Konzepte auf den Tisch
wie es funktioniert und dann werden wir
sehen ob uns das gelingt aber zurzeit
finde ich es unrealistisch Gegenwehr
auch von der FDP im
ampelkoalitionsvertrag wolle man
schließlich einen zeitigeren
bundesweiten Ausstieg nur anstreben wenn
wir jetzt symbolische zahlen wie 20 30
festlegen für das vor allen Dingen zu
einem nämlich zu mehr kosten weil die
kohlekraftwerksbetreiber wollen und
bekommen dann natürlich eine höhere
Entschädigung und damit wird Klimaschutz
nur unnötig teuer und ich glaube wir
haben nicht die Zeit für solche
Symbolpolitik und wir haben vor allen
Dingen nicht das Geld für ineffiziente
Maßnahmen ein früheres aus für die Kohle
im Osten mehr Zündstoff für den
Koalitionsausschuss nächste Woche für
eine bereits zerstrittene Ampel
die Linken Bundestagsabgeordnete Sarah
Wagenknecht will bis Ende des Jahres
entscheiden ob Sie eine neue Partei
gründet das sagte sie gegenüber ZDF
heute.de dabei spiele eine Rolle ob Sie
dazu die gesundheitliche Kraft habe als
one women show können Sie das nicht
Sarah Wagenknecht hatte angekündigt
nicht mehr für die Linke zu kandidieren
auch weil sie in ihrer Partei mit ihren
Positionen zum Ukraine Krieg aneckte
und das ganze Gespräch können Sie
natürlich in unserer ZDF heute App
nachlesen und dort erfahren sie dann
auch warum Sarah Wagenknecht noch zögert
und welche Probleme und Gefahren sie in
der möglichen Gründung einer neuen
Partei sieht
jetzt gehen wir weit zurück vor 175
Jahren gleich Europa einem Pulverfass
Unterdrückung Armut und Hunger die
Bevölkerung hatte genug und das auch in
Deutschland der 18 märz
1848 in Berlin tausende zogen damals zum
Berliner Stadtschloss forderten Presse
und Versammlungsfreiheit freie Wahlen
und eine Verfassung es folgten 17 Monate
voller Dramatik protestüge
Barrikadenkämpfe das erste
gesamtdeutsche Parlament und auch wenn
die Revolution blutig endete der
Grundstein für die Demokratie war gelegt
der Auftakt eines Gedenkjahres heute in
Berlin Stefan Merseburger
der König schießt auf sein Volk auf die
Barrikaden Berlin im revolutionsfieber
Gedenken an 1848 als das Volk für mehr
Rechte und Freiheit auf die Straße ging
auch der Bundespräsident kommt nicht auf
aber immerhin vor die Barrikade dieser
Revolution wir sollten uns eher daran
erinnern dass es die Kämpfe von 1848 und
den Folgemonaten waren die alles das in
Gang gesetzt haben wovon wir heute
profitieren Presse und Meinungsfreiheit
individuelle Freiheiten jeder Art das
Recht sich zu versammeln alles das
stammt aus dieser Zeit vor 175 Jahren
ziehen die Berliner vor das Schloss das
Militär schlägt den Aufstand blutig
nieder der König von Preußen Friedrich
Wilhelm der vierte gibt den Befehl doch
die demokratische Bewegung macht weiter
in der Frankfurter Paulskirche entsteht
ein Parlament es erarbeitet eine
Verfassung eine Delegation vielleicht
1849 nach Berlin und versucht den
Preußenkönig zu einer konstitutionellen
Monarchie zu bewegen Friedrich Wilhelm
lebt ab die Revolution scheitert
Berliner Gymnasiasten führen ein
Schauspiel auf auch das ist Teil der
revolutionsfeiern
damals wurde die für die Demokratie
gekämpft und das ist halt heute auch
noch wert das zu tun wir können
mitnehmen davon dass wir selbst als
normale Bürgerinnen und Bürger auch was
erreichen können Gedenkstunde auf dem
Friedhof der März gefallenen mehr als
250 Menschen darunter elf Frauen starben
im Kampf für Gleichberechtigung
Demokratie und Freiheit
so wir sind jetzt beim Sport und da gab
es große Emotionen vor allen Dingen im
Biathlon Christin wieder so ist kurz
vorm Abschied schöner hätte der letzte
Weltcup Sprint ihre Karriere für Denise
Herrmann Weg nicht sein können top in
der Loipe kein Schießfehler der Triumph
am legendären Holmen in Oslo und dazu
die kleine Kristallkugel großartig ihr
Abschied vom Leistungssport gestaltet
sich immer märchenhafter Smalltalk in
der königsloge bei Harald dem fünften
nicht gerade märchenhaft aber das liegen
schießen sie muss Nachladen verliert
dabei knapp 10 Sekunden gleich das
jedoch durch eine starke Laufleistung
aus wie gewohnt als das stehen schießen
fehlerfrei abläuft wird er Sieg immer
greifbarer Hannah Ölberg die Schwedin
setzt die richtigen Zeit deutlich besser
als die übrige Konkurrenz die
Olympiasiegerin und Weltmeisterin muss
gegenhalten und behält vom Vorsprung
noch drei einhalb Sekunden
ich habe die ganze Woche nur
Kristallkugel und Sprint Wertung gehört
und klar aber ich brauche anscheinend
doch ein bisschen Druck und dann
wirklich richtig zu performen als Zugabe
gibt es die kleine Kristallkugel für die
sprintbeste am Tag vor ihrem letzten
Weltcup Rennen
ja der Massenstart Faszination schief
liegen morgen die offizielle Premiere
bei den Frauen im norwegischen
wickersund den weitesten Flug im
Training markierte die Kanadierin
Alexandria lootet mit 222 m genauso weit
flog im zweiten Durchgang der
Tagessieger bei den Männern halberegner
Greiner rütt aus Norwegen kein Deutscher
übrigens unter den Top Ten
jetzt zur Fußball-Bundesliga 25 Spieltag
mit einem weiteren Dämpfer für Leipzig
Bochum besiegt RB 1:0 Stuttgart
unterliegt Wolfsburg 0:1 Augsburg
Schalke 1:1 Hoffenheim Hertha 3:1 das
Abendspiel Dortmund Köln ausführlich im
Sportstudio gestern Gladbach Bremen 2:2
die morgigen drei Partien können noch
einiges in der oberen Tabellenhälfte
verändern auch das Spitzen Duo noch ohne
Ergebnis Leipzig bleibt erstmal Dritter
kann aber überholt werden Wolfsburg
vorläufig hoch auf sieben Spannung am
Tabellenende nur zwei Punkte zwischen
den letzten vier Hoffenheim verbessert
sich auf den ersten nicht Abstiegsplatz
vorher der Schalke und dem neuen
Schlusslicht Stuttgart
und mehr dazu wie gewohnt von 23 Uhr
einem aktuellen Sportstudio zu Gast
Schalkes Stürmer Marius bülter der
vorhin per Elfmeter den Ausgleich in
Augsburg erzielt hat und jetzt noch ein
besonderer Rekord aufgestellt vom
Schweizer Marco Odermatt beim alpin
Weltcup Finale in Soltau Andorra
2042 Punkte im Gesamtweltcup 42 Punkte
mehr als der Österreicher Hermann Maier
vor 23 Jahren dazu zweimal Bestzeit im
letzten Riesenslalom des Winters der
25-Jährige wahrlich eine Klasse für sich
mit seinem 13 Saison Erfolg stellt der
zudem die Bestmarke an Siegen in einer
Saison ein die zuvor nur dem Schweden in
Master und Marcel Hirscher aus
Österreich gelangt so jetzt durchatmen
besondere Sporttag allerdings danke
schön Christin Morgen zeigt sich der
Vorfrühling von seiner wechselhaften
Seite dazu gleich mehr von Christa Orden
gegen 22 Uhr des heute-journal mit
Marietta Slomka so viel von uns danke
schön und noch einen schönen Abend für
Sie
[Musik]
guten Abend spätestens jetzt beginnt die
Natur sich auf den Frühling
vorzubereiten denn mit viel Sonne im
Süden und im Osten war es auch heute
wieder sehr mild wir erreichten 20 Grad
in Worms am Rhein und auch Jena
verpasste 20 Grad nur knapp seit dem
Nachmittag zieht jetzt eine schauerlinie
von Westen her über das Land mit
eingelagerten Gewittern heute Nachmittag
erreicht uns dann hier diese Feuchte
wolkenreiche Luft das heißt es geht im
Nordwesten weiter mit Schauern die sich
später auch südlicher und östlicher
entwickeln können in Niederbayern da wo
es klar ist da singen die Werte heute
Nacht auf zwei Grad am Niederrhein
bleibt es bei neuen Grad morgen gibt es
wieder 18 Grad in Berlin Brandenburg im
Rest des Landes mit 11 bis 15 Grad war
immer noch zweistellig und mild aber
doch etwas geringere Werte als heute
noch zum einen gibt's nämlich morgen
mehr Wolken zum anderen eine Kaltfront
aus Westen die die Schauer wieder
aufleben lässt vormittags im Süden und
im Osten noch trockene Wolken
nachmittags zieht das ganze südostwärts
und von der Nordsee her wird es dann
trockener und in diesem wechselhaften
Schauer ich sind auch lokal Gewitter
möglich dann mit kräftigerem Regen und
auch mal kräftigerem Wind den nächsten
Tagen mit dem Frühlingsbeginn am Montag
bleiben die Werte auf zweistellig und
mild aber so ein stabiles
frühlings-haft und die Natur kann ja
jeden Regen gebrauchen tschüss